it's something wrong already probably I
did sit I shouldn't wear a decision dude
I shouldn't I should explain all of it
hi guys grace Helbig here if you did not
know now you know your life is different
now you don't need to explain whether
good or bad I'm a very fun video for you
today I think I haven't tried it at all
before shooting this video so it could
be bad who knows future grace knows the
one that's editing this video definitely
knows and she's looking at like my pure
optimism right now and being like other
than her no one knows I'm sure you know
this already but if you do not myself
Mary Hart and Hannah Hart have a movie
coming out on September 23rd called
dirty 30 it's a house party film about a
30 year old and doesn't like the life
that she's living and she allows her two
best friends to throw her raging house
party and one of the fun props that we
had on set for the house party scenes
was a shot ski if you do not know what a
shot ski is it is the foundation is a
ski used for skiing on top of that ski
are three equidistance relatively secure
shot glasses why is that crazy
for the purpose of three people being
able to take a shot at the same time I'm
going to be really fun in this video to
try and DIY a very very homemade shot
ski the base of a shot ski is a ski and
if you have a ski laying around
congratulations you're rich all you need
for the base is a very narrow long
structurally sound piece of some
material that's relatively flat on top
so you can put some shots on top to make
my base I took a cardboard box that I
ordered off of Amazon for really well
because it was already folded into which
made it like extra sound so I took
another corporate box tray straight down
the side of that Cobra box and tried to
cut out my narrow strip of cardboard
that was doubled over but the problem I
have with this piece is that it's a
little flimsy see so I'm going to just
reinforce its structure with old kabob
sticks yeah I knew you came in XS who
actually makes 100 kabobs
I'm takes on my wooden skewers hot glue
them along the inside of this homemade
Trotsky folded over and hopefully
reinforce it let's see what happens
shall we
[Music]
so I think our cardboard structure is
secure I'm just going to take some
packing tape and wrap the edges of it
just to be extra
[Music]
so there we have our shots keyboards the
fun thing is now you can decorate your
homemade shot ski however you want
depending on the theme of your party the
best thing to do in my opinion is to put
some sort of message underneath the
shots keys so when everyone's taking the
shot everyone else that will clearly be
watching will receive a very direct
message so tada art I mean ideally these
wouldn't be here but sometimes you grip
things like that our last step is that
you're gonna take some shot glasses and
glue them to the top of your shot ski a
lot of shots Keys use actual glass shot
glasses but we're doing homemade so
we're using some plastic shot glasses
somehow these were in my cupboard and my
surprise no I am surprised that I use
the word covered though I basically want
to space out your shot glasses so that
when any three people are taking this
shot ski they don't have to deal with
like their faces their cheeks touching
each other's cheeks that's always like a
not necessarily what you want spends on
the time of the night but we're gonna
hot glue some of our shot glasses down
to our shot ski here we go if you're
really concerned about like the sanitary
issues you've really doubled these up
and then take away the shot as people
take them oh my god and there we go
there's your homemade shot ski we got
three let me show you how it works
by myself hold on hey friends let me
take a shot yeah of course you do
we're having such a fun time here we go
together all three of us one two three
is that me to do crazy in half Wow
Frankfort you know there is how to make
your own homemade shot ski which I'm
pretty sure is entirely recyclable until
one of you tell me that it is completely
not speaking of dirty thirty dumbness
and DIY my character in thirty thirty
her name is Evie and she is charitable
but not for necessarily the most
well-known charities and she has di wide
a PSA for charity that she really
cares about but I don't know if anyone
else does and reluctantly she has
brought on her two best friends to help
her in her PSA so take a look and eby's
I don't even know how you describe it
enjoy so Evie how is the fundraising
coming along you know for the bald
llamas alpacas with alopecia oh is is
that a thing yeah and actually I have
already raised over half of their goal
you're here hello
I'm Evie every day every year Thank You
Kate every year literally tens of
alpacas are afflicted with a terrible
debilitating disease early onset alpaca
alopecia is a growing epidemic but we
can stop it actually Charlie we can't
not alone at least that's right we need
your help please help us find a cure
with each donation alpacas like Elliot
will get closer to having their hair
back so give us your money or some
strands of your hair just cut them right
off of your head
don't need no gingers just in yellow all
brown ones - don't come in red give us
your money
[Music]
party time do you wanna have sex
oh wow that's me what is happening you
crazy
oh I wanna bathe
[Music]
also don't forget to pre hundred 30 30
on iTunes the link is down below in the
description box thank you guys so much
for watching if you like this video give
it a thumbs up and subscribe to this
channel because that would be just so
expletive great